[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a little tired but Gronk reporting
Tom Brady posting yesterday on social
media the video of him summoning Rob
Gronkowski from retirement and now a
member of the Tampa Bay Buccaneers in
the trade that happened on Tuesday out
of nowhere and it was over and done like
that and now Gronk met with the media on
Wednesday via video conference and
addressed a variety of things
here's Grogg explaining why he needed a
full year off before returning to
football for sure I said it from the
beginning that I want to come back
unless if I'm feeling and unless if I'm
feeling good and feeling healthy and I'm
feeling like I'm ready to go and now
this is the case this is the time it
definitely wasn't last year my body 100%
needed a rest you know I played football
for whatever 15 years straight college
high school and a foul and I was taking
hits surgeries everything my body 100%
need to rest
I had no fire last year even an end of
the season to come back but you know as
the time rolled on the last couple weeks
you know I started really picking it up
Rob Gronkowski not a surprise Chris that
he needed to have a little bit of time
off he had so many injuries so many
surgeries concussion concerns and he was
just worn out he was worn out by New
England he was worn out by the Patriot
way he was worn out by Bill Belichick
and now he's had a full reset mental and
physical and he's ready to go and it all
makes sense well yeah it doesn't make
sense and you know yes first physical as
he's played the position over his career
and some of the injuries he's had like
we talked about yesterday I mean you
know those were know like oh we're gonna
swipe that under the rug type injuries
they were serious plates in his elbow
you know back surgeries leg surgeries I
mean he's had at all and I understand
that I think he was beat to crap he did
he lost his fire but he you're off yeah
I'm I'm sure it refreshed him when I can
you know even the fact that again he
says they're like a few weeks ago you
know again it just leads me to believe
he started working
for that WWE WrestleMania and I think he
started going damn I kind of feel good
and this Tampa Bay thing is interesting
and Bradys there and you know I just
find that very interesting I wonder if
that's what got him gone too regardless
he's ready to go and man I love that
social media conscious thing that is
amazing and it's an amazing story right
now the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and Gronk
said yesterday that he first discussed
potentially coming out of retirement and
joining Brady two months ago here's
Gronk on that issue we actually got
together about two months ago and he we
rarely talked about what his decision
was gonna be what where I'm at
I said I'm definitely interested in your
decision that you make I mean I didn't
put any pressure on him I said but if
there's a right opportunity out there
and and you you go somewhere and the
opportunity is right even if you go back
to the Patriots and I feel like the
opportunity is right there's a there's a
possible chance that I will definitely
love to reconnect and that's where the
conversation started a little bit and he
was all fired up and juiced up about it
he clearly was I mean even when you have
OJ Howard and Cameron braid is your
tight ends in Tampa Bay neither guy all
due respect is Gronk and to add grog to
Mike Evans and Chris Godwin and it's
just it it really adds a level of
excitement fascination and who the hell
knows if it's gonna work but it's fun to
think about it it's fun to talk about it
it's fun to have Gronk back in the NFL
the NFL isn't the same without Gronk in
it and just this idea of taking we're
not just one iconic player from one of
the greatest franchises we've ever seen
in any sport but two of them and moving
them to the same town in the same
offseason that's unprecedented
unprecedented and you know I mean you
know how I feel about it I mean
Gronkowski is the greatest tight end
ever
you know Brady certainly in that
conversation for his you know
quarterback position it's amazing
let alone you know again just the star
power that was already there and the
good football players that were on the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers roster you know and
then you add
yes Gronk and Brady to Tampa with you
know Bill Bruce Arians and his you know
unique coaching style and personality I
just think it's gonna be so many great
moments you know leading up to the
season hopefully if we have it and
during this season because they're gonna
be you know I just have a hard time
believing they're not going to be in the
conversation from one of the better
teams in the NFC South I do I just I
think Bruce Arians as type of coach
they'll be able to feed off this energy
and hope you able to get the team to
rally around it and Brady's gonna give
them belief and Gronk is going to give
them belief and it's just going to be
just the nudge they needed to kind of
get over the top from mediocrity to now
we're kind of in the cream of the crop
conversation so that's what makes it
awesome
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports